[Music]
[Applause]
northwestern came back to beat nebra
nebraska 31-28 in dublin during week
zero on saturday they host duke next
saturday september 10th he's the head
coach of northwestern now known as paddy
fitzgerald who joins us on the program
patty how are you
i'm doing great dan a little jet lag but
it's great to be back in the office
buddy did you pick up any accent when
you were there in dublin
uh lovely yeah
lovely show yeah absolutely yeah no it
was great uh it was an amazing first
class trip the air lingus folks
college football classic there
really good really good deal man i mean
you know you you can say it's not a bowl
game but you take your team for a trip
for a week it was it was special
do you realize it's in dublin like at
any point during the game does it feel
different sound different
well you know i didn't see it but it was
pointed out to me and it wasn't a
surprise but uh there was an issue with
the point of sale so it sounded like the
guinness was free flowing for about a
quarter and a half
and uh my eighth grade son shows me
right after the game hey yeah great win
did you see they had the cup stretch
from the bottom of the stadium all the
way to the top so
it was pretty evident right away that we
were uh we were in dublin when you went
over there with your wife uh earlier
this year
like what are you looking for family
history-wise
well my grandparents on my dad's side
both immigrated from ireland so it was
one of those situations where we land
they took us to the genealogy museum
called epic and that stands for every
person is connected uh there to ireland
and
the genealogists it was incredible so
that starts the day i see a ticket to my
boat that my grandmother came over on i
was very close with her when i was
growing up to where then i go out to a
town called nerney uh in county kildare
and meet my cousin and where my
grandmother was baptized in the church
she went to in the school before she
left and came over with her sister i
mean it was it was surreal it was very
emotional and then i was able to have my
dad make the trip with me here for the
game and that was his first time to
ireland
of his fam immediate family he's the
only one still alive all his siblings
have passed so
it was a very emotional uh time a
surreal time and a lot of fun but most
importantly our guys handled it well and
played really i think a physical brand
of ball that uh you know hopefully made
all of our fans proud
who came up with the idea to give
tribute to the irish flag on the n on
the northwestern helmet yeah that was
our equipment staff mike valentine
curtis shane or eric jackson they just
do a great job uh and then they designed
the whole thing and
i thought that came out pretty neat uh
it looked great played who knew it would
play so well the green the white the
orange would play so well with the
purple
it looked great it was just a nice
little subtle touch
um
were you expecting the onside kick
no well they kind of extended their
widest guy earlier and we had talked
about either they're going to try to
chip a pass or watch watch the bunt
that's what we call it but we had
actually we just in your checklist of
training camp we had funded the ball
kind of in each gap throughout camp and
andrew clear one of our captains was the
was you know kind of the frontline guy
that recovered it and he was on point
you know during training camp watching
the fun we caught lots of funny stuff
and
um but what's the wise guy what what's
that mean
well the widest guy i'm sorry so they
they took their
you know tyler haskins widened with them
maybe a little bit too wide a couple of
reps prior
so you could kind of tell something was
maybe up a note we we didn't predict
that that was going to happen on that
play but you know ac just handled it
well
you know as always play with poise he's
an older player and uh there's a heck of
a kick we just we got executed on that
play which ended up turning momentum uh
but i'd rather focus more on on the play
that our guy made then maybe the media's
kind of looked at the choice i mean i i
applaud frosty for being aggressive you
know we're both coming off tough seasons
and you know you're trying to go make a
play to win a football game and you know
to our credit our young man made the
play
you know when you're designing offenses
now it feels like it's all about the
passing game you're running for over 200
yards against nebraska um
you know kind of counter-intuitive to
what we expect with success in college
football why is that
i think you got to know who you are
right and uh you know we've got an
identity that we want to have we want to
be built on the line of scrimmage and we
want to be able to control the clock and
uh you know really play complimentary
football that's how we've been able to
be pretty consistent here in two of the
last four years playing the big ten
championship game and
you know
those are the type of guys we get kind
of a white collar school with a blue
collar mentality and we want guys to
play the game the right way tough and
physical and uh you know i think we took
a big step it last year looked like we
hadn't been in the building in the
weight room because of covet and you
know it's a developmental program that
showed well
jay hutton our strength staff most
importantly our players bought into it
man they they looked they looked like a
big ten offensive and defensive line on
saturday and i think nebraska's gonna be
very good they're very talented
um you know and they've got a lot of
transfers that those pieces kind of gel
together man they are explosive and and
we're glad we got them in week one i saw
where marcus freeman reacted to finding
out that they were like a 17 and a half
point underdog notre dame against ohio
state
you guys started out at like 12 point
underdog
do you are you aware of it and can you
use it
you know with your players as motivation
yeah i mean yeah yeah you can i mean
again
motivation is a t-shirt and a sign on
the wall it doesn't matter what ball
goes up in the air right i mean that
motivation's like getting them through
tuesday practice when it's 90 you know
at the end of the day who cares but
yeah i mean i don't i don't blame people
for feeling the way that we did they got
they took a lot of high-profile
transfers they got it after our rear end
a year ago in lincoln
uh and it was a credit to the way they
played and how poorly we played and um
you know that's just the way that it is
and
uh you know i'm sure we made a lot of
northwestern fans very happy on saturday
what do you mention these days
uh not enough yeah not enough i i i need
to get back in the weight room a little
bit more but uh if i had a bench off
with the big ten coaches
who's the strongest head coach in the
big ten
uh uh not being able to say myself i
would probably go with uh either i'd go
with frosty or mel
okay so mel tucker or bit but you would
take yourself over those two you're
allowed to include yourself
yeah
okay that's what we want we want
bulletin board material there yeah no i
mean yeah yeah absolutely yeah and then
we we'd have to do a whole crossfit
thing it couldn't just be the bench
press you know let's go i'm not a runner
anymore let's get on the elliptical for
30 minutes see how high you can go and
how how many miles you can get i'd be
all for that i like it i like it i'm
kind of part of the skinny fat society
of america dan i look good in a shirt
he's known as paddy fitch
um hey congratulations on the win good
luck against duke thanks for joining us
coach appreciate the opportunity my
friend go cats thanks that's uh pat
fitzgerald